[Music]
and sounds like a scam news that cost
you that scam song of a scam song that
one
the scams are submitted by all pain no
gain a youtuber has been accused of a
scam after her Louis Vuitton giveaway
turned into a mess I like it I'm not
confident that he's looking for
reactions I never know what gives you
the impression that I look for reactions
oh your eyes oh I'm just waiting if it's
time for her to talk so you can
interrupt I like your glasses - nice I'm
trying - oh I thought you're gonna wear
yours oh I will glasses brothers you did
say that I try to find a match he match
you on oh yeah well the grandfather
glasses those are grandfather glasses
well you guys like they have the the
fist rim thing with them and I think
those are bows is but I don't know no
there's like green marble looking yeah
those are cool oh my god you look like
the guy from Heroes it matches it
matches I am the father from heroes
glasses - you're the father from every
movie ever made
- yeah yeah he doesn't play a dad in our
pilot nope these pictures pretty closely
but he could be a boy six to six let's
go you could be bad yeah I cut you so
this story here is have you guys ever
heard of this chick named ELISA violet
nope Oh sounds familiar
so she is an influencer who has over 3.9
million subscribers on Wow tube and has
eight point eight million followers on
Instagram wowzers that's a lot she's
popping I've been living under a rock
oh damn she's tubing hard out there
she's hard I mean hot where's she hard
at those titties I don't kind of hard
what she's gorgeous so anyway I didn't
say she wasn't I said her titties look I
didn't think you said she wasn't I'm
just saying she's gorgeous and hard
duties are kind of cool too
statement sounded like an argument you
said what she's gorgeous
no they what to yours and then I added
my like it was a period rage she's
gorgeous have you never heard the phrase
big hard titties yeah usually followed
by they suck they'll get his breast
implants oh I see what kind of kind
addition me tech review she good I
thought she was a freaking farm DIY
person oh the homestead thing yeah so
she posted this photo here I saw it
somewhere maybe people did you could you
submit to this contest so she posted
this photo and this was the original
caption which says wait oMG we're giving
away free Louis Vuitton bags to a few of
my followers hearts to enter it's simple
one go to at cheek now you must follow
everyone they are following parentheses
it only takes 30 seconds to then come
back here and tag to friends it's that
easy
I'm announcing the winner on my story
Friday night hashtag ad this was back in
August
um August 2000 no she didn't deliver so
she said that she would announce the
winners that Friday which was August
30th oh and the days after that she
changed her caption to long day
parentheses announcing the winners
Friday so she took everything out else
out about like and the handle at cheek
handle and everything and then
eventually you should change it again
and just left it as long day well maybe
after she announced it she didn't want
it so then that's the thing that's I
kind of like people were saying it's
kind of weird what's long day mean she
hasn't had a chance to but she's had a
long day so she hasn't had a chance to
pick winners oh I see
so her followers were trying to follow
the at cheek handle but then it they
realized that it was a broken link
Oh bad Instagram page no longer existed
hmm so she was like ah [ __ ] I don't want
to do it anymore
no so then it seems like what happened
here was that there was miscommunication
or communication problems and this is
what caused the drama so then the
company created a backup account called
at cheek wins
and then that's where they shared a new
set of instructions for the giveaway
their actual caption says this like this
and it says when Louie Vuitton with
Elissa violet all you need to do is
enter it ok all you need to do to enter
is follow everyone we're following and
tech to friends below good luck heart
eligibility the sweepstakes is only open
to legal US residents currently residing
in the 50 state law who are at least 18
years of age at the time of entry so
turns out they finally did announce
three winners on in early September from
the @qi Quinn's account but then once
the winners were announced they've just
totally go stood on the winners oh no
communicate at all like one of the
winners who seems to be the only one
that is actually like qualified to win
she's 19 from California
the other two seemed to be underage and
like elsewhere so this one winner her
name is Vanessa so she kept messaging
trying to find out like hey like which
bags that I win and like even submitted
a form that they wanted her to submit
and till this day as of like from what
I've read in this story she still has
not received her Louie Vuitton bag so
it's just like they've totally ghost it
on her see can't trust girls to [ __ ]
organize nothing dude dude an but you
can trust girls to try to get her free
[ __ ] yep yup yeah but you know what you
can't expect is us delivering laughter
so subscribe yes make sure y'all stay
tuned cuz I will never [ __ ] you in the
rectum like this whole house wait what
you just [ __ ] me a tip cuz you said
girls can't organize [ __ ] no I mean like
we don't [ __ ] we deliver though girls
wait when have you done a giveaway are
we gonna give wine everybody general see
me why are you so selfish so you won't
give things away okay by the way I just
did a giveaway I gave away 33 McDonald's
cards to my fans what a giving person a
long
I ordered and I think every way Abbasid
jewelry okay but I didn't ask you I
asked her so yeah well you think
woman-hating days on the show doesn't
like her fans another day I'm a [ __ ] I
did a giveaway I gave you a watch what
kind of watch let it in Churchill hunch
it was a brand deal wasn't it you did it
for the brand new or not because you
love your fans you hate your face
they're all brand deals they're all
brand deals it's a brand deal - yeah
McDonald defend yourself he's giving up
food to hungry people yep so we're all
extreme no it was for me those cards
weren't for me and I said I don't need
this [ __ ] I'm trying to lose weight so I
gave it to them it's mutually beneficial
oh but if you weren't trying to lose I
got a lot of other [ __ ] I'm about to
give away too but I can't organize so
I'm not gonna do it
that's like celebrities that don't like
soup go to soup kitchens and give soup
to the homeless yeah because they don't
like this they're not gonna eat the soup
so why why let a better person than Joe
cuz I really wanted the Joey I give away
really did you really that doesn't makes
you stupid
no very giving you're so quiet why don't
you go to Claire's just buy jewelry and
then just give them that and then keep
it secure oh you should be friends with
this one right I mean this chick I like
this too yeah [ __ ] Brandi from Louis
Vuitton no it was from this cheek
company which by the way what is she is
like a luxury platform luxury so the
company [ __ ] failed Yankees the
account went away so that's confusing
but even the cheek wins account is just
really likes candy just everything
sounds really scammy so people are like
what the [ __ ] you thought you were gonna
scam us and get away with it
but the company saying the guess you got
scammed - butt cheek - whatever yeah but
it's just maybe but then a big
transparent about a communicator I think
the people like her followers are just
like the [ __ ] dude that you could talk
to it like tell us what's happening but
maybe I guess in her defense she could
possibly have like some legal boundaries
around it I don't know well I hope that
the mother Teresa of our time mr. beast
finds these people and gives them the
Louie Vuitton they deserve oh we're
talking about mr. beast later today well
we should be talking about in every
video as far as
because he does a lot of good out there
he does a lot of Giveaways not like geo
she doesn't do it come on be nice oh you
don't know Gino giveaways you just said
that she does she gives her she gives
her followers codes all the time you
just shoved her off a bridge you pushed
her back you know what this means you
have to stay subscribe because we're
gonna do a giveaway to make up for all
of Geo selfishness what will you guys
give away I mean clarify that how's it
not having her back yeah maybe we should
just play it back okay no cuz I wanna
know cuz I'm like hey she's been getting
like she's helping them get a discount
why I'm not so good they still have to
buy something too but at the full price
yeah but it still feels like they're
shilling something out it's not it's not
a give away for it to shut you the [ __ ]
up I'm gonna step in here cuz yeah if
you have my back thank you so I've
actually given a hundred bucks away for
no [ __ ] reason just like someone
could have a nice [ __ ] day oh we're
on my Instagram cuz I was like you know
what I'm gonna give you dude you're
gonna get so many DMS now where people
are like geo give me [ __ ] free money
what you do you just promote it yeah dan
there's no winning with Joe well
actually I sent him home on a free month
I sent a Visa card but I didn't want to
promote that such a good person we at
least he got it on video didn't you I
would have never gave out cash people
don't deserve [ __ ] [ __ ] that what would
you give up oh I'd give out things that
I don't want that nothing like the
McDonald's one man's trash is another
man's treasure and that's true that's
what I do but cash is my treasure and I
don't want to give that out would you
ever give away one of your instruments
or your flutes
that's my treasure right there's someone
out there that would want it hey what
about all the aspiring musicians that
are like oh my dream was to be a [ __ ]
kazoo player
new one huh give them a new kazoo now
your saliva because I want the new one
and I think I have my own one that I
don't want it you can have this old one
that's a given
see how give me that damn it I can't win
here Punk man I gave away free money now
it's still a bad guy
yeah right because you don't do it from
the heart what matters is what comes
from here you you guys are too business
so you have to have the personal
connection with the fanbase you two
calculator
yeah and when you when you have a
personal connection with the fans out
there that's when they're like oh this
has been in Joe's mouth deep in his
mouth he doesn't want it anymore
yeah that's a personal what the new ones
let me be a good fan and take his trash
so he could have the better thing that's
what true fans would do
I heard eldest one time he saw a couple
pulled over on the side of the road and
their their their car was broken and so
he gave them his car no no probably just
cuz he didn't want anymore because he's
like guys all convertible I bought this
[ __ ] 300 miles ago so they did Joe's
logic that's a good guy yeah he was a
good man hat is a good guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]